we have a voicemail number which is 219
to david p here is a voicemail i
received
about potential trump vs biden debates
let's take a listen
hey david this is aristotle from modesto
california i just had a quick question
um what do you think about the debates
that will be happening with
joe biden and donald trump because
obviously joe biden has
empathized that and is also excited to
debate trump and do you think joe
biden's gonna you know
maybe sweep the floor with trump on the
debates because
at this point on the show you have
covered that trump has
been sweaty and just very just nervous
on everything so do you think
trump's gonna be a nervous wreck and
that would would that give joe biden a
advantage let me know and also
uh i love the show okay yeah it got cut
off there but that seemed like it was a
very very
worthwhile praise of the david pakman
show so a couple different things number
one i don't know if there are going to
be debates i
at this point i really don't know i've
said before i don't care if there are
debates this is an election
where i am uniquely unconcerned with
debates
we know the the differences are so vast
between these candidates that i don't
need debates i don't need conventions i
don't i really don't need any of this
stuff
um the the path forward is very clear
now
if we learned anything from the bernie
vs biden debate remember when the
democratic primary got down to just
bernie versus biden you had a lot of
people saying oh my god dementia joe
he's going to implode bernie's going to
mop
the floor with him and take over the
primary
and it was just like very uneventful and
biden did fine enough and as we know he
ended up
very easily winning the primary in
general the expectation that debates are
going to dramatically
turn the race i think are overblown
expectations
that being said cognitively trump is not
where he was
three and a half years ago and i readily
admit that joe biden has also slowed
down
uh um notably over the last 10 years you
know since he debated paul ryan i guess
that was eight years ago in 2012
joe biden also he's close to 80 years
old and it's a different joe biden i
don't uh
have any interest in pretending that's
not the case so
there is always the possibility that uh
either of the uh candidate could
do sort of self-inflicted damage uh due
to a poor debate performance but
anybody suggesting that it's clear that
the debates are going to be so one-sided
that it will
destroy one candidate's possibilities um
i i don't see that as as based in fact
and
again i don't know that there are going
to be debates we will hopefully learn
specifics about that soon we have a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about some who are calling for
biden to simply refuse to debate trump
we'll talk about the optics versus the
strategy and
we will talk about these mystery seeds
that americans are receiving
i actually received some of these and i
have a story to tell about this
and we will discuss that and so much
more on today's bonus show
two ways to get access to the bonus show
become a member at joinedpakman.com
or become a patron at
david patreon.com show